my friend kelsey hightower once said
containers are the price of admission to
using kubernetes
so to get started with kubernetes we'll
need to dive deeper into what containers
really are with a whole universe of
things to learn it's important to start
with the essentials
let's go over the concepts that make
kubernetes usable scalable and just
downright
awesome are you ready so kubernetes is a
container orchestrator
last time you said that containers were
packaged up services what does that
actually mean
yeah containers were built to deploy
smaller services
with isolation and consistency but
they're not actually a new concept
containers are based on some underlying
concepts from the linux kernel
namespaces and c groups right namespaces
make sure that individual processes
can't
see the details of other processes and c
groups control how much resources a
process can use like cpu
memory these two concepts are all about
giving a process
isolation protecting it from interfering
with other processes
as well as protecting itself from others
virtual machines can give a similar
level of isolation but only by packing
the whole
operating system with it for plenty of
applications
the os isn't necessary and it certainly
takes up a lot of resources
containers on the other hand only focus
on the application and its dependencies
making them more lightweight now apps
don't need to worry about if some
developer had hard-coded python 2.7 into
the path variable
that's an oddly specific example but yes
there's actually a few different
container runtimes but one of the most
popular
is docker they built an api that helped
app developers build containers
and a platform to run them the same way
regardless of which machine they run on
right it's all about letting the app
developer define what they want the
runtime to look like
instead of spending time messing around
with the kernel this is all done in a
docker file
why don't we zoom in on one good idea if
you were working on a simple flask app
your docker file might look like this
the first line
is the base image the app should use you
can choose from all sorts of base images
so you can choose one that has exactly
what you need with
less overhead making your container
smaller
next these lines tell the container what
commands to run when being initialized
your flask app is definitely going to
need python so this installs python pip
and flask now the copy command will grab
files from your local environment and
copy them into the container
so your local app.py file gets copied to
slash opt
slash app.py and the container now has
your app files
and finally the entry point command lets
your container run as an executable
actually starting up the flask
application which is a few lines
you've created a container awesome but
but but you would still have to manually
deploy the container
manage it and handle situations like if
the container goes down or if you want
to roll out an upgrade to your app code
and now we've come back to kubernetes
kubernetes takes care of managing your
containers
no matter if you have one or a thousand
just like how your docker file explains
what you want your container to do
you can configure kubernetes for what
you want your whole cluster to do
you might hear this called the desired
state and that's probably the coolest
thing about kubernetes
you tell it what the desired state for
the cluster is and it automates
everything from
pods nodes load balancers and more whoa
uh hold on that's a lot of new stuff
let's start
with the essentials we were just talking
about containers
so what's a pod a pod is like a
collection of multiple containers
sort of a pseudo application it could
just be one app or it could be multiple
different ones that need to work
together
for example let's go back to your flask
app okay
so i know how to build a container
how do we turn this into a pod well if
that's your desired state
we can tell kubernetes to make it happen
here's a yaml file that gives the
desired state for a pod
this metadata section gives a way for
kubernetes to group
pods and other resources together and
we'll dive deeper into that later
for now the key part is this spec
section
here's where you name the pod and tell
it which image to use
since this is a simple pod your
container is the only one running here
there's also a port section so the
container can be accessed through the
web
on the default http port 80. once this
config is put into a kubernetes cluster
kubernetes knows what you want to do and
is in charge of ensuring that your
actual state
matches your desired state that's a
great start
uh but where is the pod actually going
to run
for that we'll need to talk more about
nodes and deployments
let's cover that in the next episode
sounds good so
today we covered more about containers
and why they became so popular
then we started to talk about how
kubernetes works with containers
but there's still plenty more to cover
wow
that was a lot of great info on
containers but now
we need to figure out how they run ok
stay tuned everybody
if you want to get hands on check out
the link in the description and if you
enjoyed the episode
subscribe for more
you